in another world Gabby would be in an
audience band Gabby's band name would be
something that's like more like a phrase
like Panic at the Disco like for real
with a question mark Gabby's Audi's
aesthetic was definitely like razored
hair Crest straight like the ponytail is
just a little too strong because it
hasn't been pressed that much really
colorful pants of hair on pants probably
something ridiculous like that in
another world Liz started playing
pickleball with Jimmy but then she
becomes the best pickleball player in
the world she's playing for New York
playing pickleball where they have the
US Open weeds the team is called the
crunchers we're gonna go green and pink
so we take the palm tree aesthetic from
LA but we're still in the east coast but
we still remember where we're from in
another world I'm thinking Sean we a
problem he'd have something intelligent
like mind control like if I tell you in
your mind what to do how you gonna fight
me you don't want to fight that guy just
diesel in a suit and not on your best
day Alice needs to let go a little bit
like if she was a lead singer of like a
punk band in Seattle in like the 90s I
feel like she could really let all her
anger and all her pain go as an homage
to Phoebe Bridgers the song that Alice
listens to I know the end I think great
man's name I think that Derek would like
to move to the Italian Riviera he would
get a nice pair of Speedos and he'd get
it maybe a Vespa scooter with pockets on
the side and he'd fill it every day with
fresh sausages and flowers he would open
a small Cafe everyone knows your name
and you really can ReDiscover yourself
through the coffee
[Music]